pascal rosa responsable de la collecte
de fonds tiers à la direction des
collections de l'ina aujourd'hui dans
les fonds de l'ina il ya plus de 350
fontière c'est plutôt à partir des
années 2000 que li na s'est mis à avoir
une vraie politique de collecte de fonds
on s'est tournée prioritairement faire
les acteurs de notre écosystème naturel
c'est à dire des sociétés de production
des diffuseurs comme comme tf1 et puis
assez vite néanmoins on à diversifier
notre collecte vers des acteurs
extérieurs au monde de l'audiovisuel
il y avait la volonté d'élargir l'offre
commerciale de l'ina en fait mais il y
avait aussi un enjeu plus patrimoniale
qui était lié à l'émergence de
production audiovisuelle en fait un peu
dans plein de domaines c'est à dire que
des acteurs se sont mis à tourner la
vidéo enregistrée du son sans être
forcément des spécialistes de ça et un
moment donné c'est poser la question de
d'archivés s'atténue mais moi il ya
quand même des axes forts qui se sont
dessinées à c'est au ghana 1 par exemple
qu'est le sport où il y avait un enjeu
pour le coup commercial vraiment
centrale puisque c'est un contenu qui
est très demandé sur le marché de
l'audiovisuel
donc on a noué des très nombreux
partenariats avec des acteurs du sport
alors c'est peut être à etsaut pour le
tour de france l'automobile club de
l'ouest pour les 24 heures du mans
beaucoup de fédérations la fédération
française de football et beaucoup
d'autres il ya un axe plus patrimoniale
qui s'est dégagé notamment autour de
tout ce qui est l'institution culturelle
lina énormément collecter de fonds liées
au spectacle vivant essentiellement des
captations de représentation est aussi
parfois de répétition on a des
partenariats comme ça avec l'opéra de
paris avec la comédie française le
théâtre de l'odéon des théâtres aussi en
région comme au théâtre national de
strasbourg
on a aussi une activité en tout ce qui
est art contemporain avec l'enjeu la
d'archivés tout ce qui est art vidéo
travail comme ça que le centre pompidou
avec le cnap également le centre
national des arts plastiques
ces dernières années on a beaucoup nous
et de partenariat avec la presse filmée
c'est vrai que maintenant avec le web
des acteurs qui avant était entièrement
sur les cris se met à produire de
l'image donc on a noué des partenariats
avec life pays avec le parisien plus
récemment avec télérama alors une
réplique de la douleur qui vous restent
en tête